you don't impress me for a minute I'll
have your carpet bombs in five you will
be dead by then in many ways Mortal
Kombat acts as an evolution of 2011's
Mortal Kombat the gruesome fatality is
an xray attacks that Mortal Kombat is
known for are more gut-wrenching than
ever made more convincing thanks to
significantly improved visuals it would
be easy to get caught up in the violence
on display and forget that there's a
deep and challenging fighting game
underneath but it wouldn't be your fault
nearly everything you do in Mortal
Kombat X as a means to witness or unlock
new forms of bodily torture from a
practical standpoint it doesn't get in
the way of the matter at hand combat but
you're never far off from seeing yet
another brutal act in the name of Victor
like the last game Mortal Kombat X
delivers a robust story the fight for
the throne of the out world realm has
stirred up great turmoil causing fallen
elder gods and demons alike to vie for
the seat by any means necessary
what a new generation has risen to
defend earth realm including the
offspring of classic Mortal Kombat
characters the influx of new faces could
inspire a renewed interest for some fans
but when characters like Cassie cage and
Jackie Briggs so closely mimic their
parents fighting styles and
personalities you wouldn't be alone if
you saw the generation gap as a bit
blurry
there's anything positive to say about
Mortal Kombat X's story it's that the
evolving relationship between Cassie's
parents Johnny and Sonya retroactively
Lee tells Cassie's story providing
glimpses into the best and worst
qualities that her parents may have
passed on elsewhere you need to have a
strong interest in the series lore if
you hope to enjoy the rest of the story
once you start digging into the real
fight you find a fighting system that's
both deep and accessible the roster is
comprised of 25 characters but with
three variations each it's even bigger
than it seems at first blush the core
moves sets are similar across each
character's variation making special
move sets the only real difference with
so many options even if you don't fall
in love with every variation of your
favorite fighter you at least have a
chance to find something interesting
about a character you might have
otherwise overlooked the action of
Maulik on that X is smoother than the
previous key forgoing some of its
stiffness in favor of greater flow
during combat in addition to the usual
selection of normal attacks throws and
special attacks while the combat X
brings the last games meter back
allowing you to power up a special move
break an opponent's combo or dish out a
comeback move in the form of a violent
x-ray
[Music]
there are devastating combos waiting for
skilled players who learn how to perform
it and in the Battle of fighting game
Giants a well-placed breaker move can
make the difference between a beat-down
in a victory the test your luck mode
makes a comeback where combat modifiers
alter everything from physics
environmental effects your ability use
special attacks and this adds a great
amount of variety to standard combat
this system is also applied to the new
living towers which are a series of
challenges that NetherRealm Studios
refreshes hourly daily and weekly Mortal
Kombat X has a lot of optional content
to unlock within the Crypt which is a
mode where you roam through a map in
first-person spinning coins that you
earn in the game to unearth treasure
there are over 100 items to unlock
including art and character skins and
finishing moves and you're going to have
to play a lot of model Kombat X in order
to purchase everything the act of
digging through the Crypt is in itself
somewhat enjoyable as you hunt for items
to unlock new areas but quite often the
things you unlock are underwhelmed you
have to spend money blindly hoping to
unlock a new character scanner fatality
rather than a piece of fan art and
considering it can take a while to earn
enough money our grateful purchase is
all it takes to feel like the entire
process is a waste of time the netcode
that drives more Kombat X's online
matches is adequate but like all online
fighting games you want it to matches
the play perfectly and others where lag
just ruins the fight when you do get
into a fight with a poor connection you
may as well exit and search for new
opponent because it'll be difficult to
pull off simple combos and special moves
when it matters at that point it's a
competition between man and machine
thankfully this is a rare occurrence
there's so much to do in Mullica Kombat
X and a well of fighting styles to
explore that you'll have to try pretty
hard to grow bored of it this is the
most visually stunning world combat to
date to mixing over-the-top injustice
like moves with an eye-catching visual
style the violence within isn't going to
sit well with everybody and while it
sometimes feels like a promise of a
brutal finishing move overshadows the
core fighting game within when you see
through it you'll appreciate that Mortal
Kombat X is a great fighting game that's
merely dressed with dark humor rather
than one that's defined by that and that
alone
[Music]
you